hello my name is caleb debbie and
welcome back to game review game review
game review man review me a game as fast
as you can today we're gonna be taking a
look at a game between alexander
alekhine
and jose raul capablanca this game of
course in the World Championship match
all the way back in 1927 in this game
kappa blanka chose d4 the alkyne
responded d5 we have c4 e6 Knight c3
Knight f6 Bishop g5 from kappa blanka
knight bt7 your standard Queens gambit
declined III from white defending this
pawn now the bishop outside the pawn
chain we have Bishop e7 Knight f3
castles and rook c1 from white the idea
here is white is delaying the
development of this bishop so as to
avoid losing a tempo after D takes c4
black chooses the move a 6 which is a
pretty common idea and now generally
these days white captures on d5 not
allowing D takes c4 and the reason for
that is we'll see after a three black
simply captures and while white gets
developed this Bishop immediately it's
going to be forced back with a move b5
and this is what we see happen in the
game first though black concludes this
move h6 Bishop h4 and now we go in for
the line I just showed and after b5 for
some reason here Kevin block it shows
the e2 square for the bishop I think
honestly d3 is just a better more active
square instead though Bishop e2 you see
Bishop b7 and we see castles from white
c5 from black no D takes d5 of course D
takes c5 from white black captures with
Knight takes e5 now simply 94 and what
we have going on here is a very
symmetrical pawn structure actually of
course it's four versus four on the
Kings side and two versus two on the
Queen side but blacks pieces are simply
better placed to to handle this position
94 from white is
actually not my favorite move from kappa
blanka black is now simply going to
develop very naturally bring his rooks
to these files and his pieces are simply
better placed to to handle this
structure the Knights working together
to control the e4 square and we'll see
some very instructive maneuvers from
alkyne shortly
first and foremost though rooks - the
open files we see b4 from white the
knight retreats back to d7 and now the
problem for white we'll see quite
shortly bishop g3 kind of a weird move
just guarding some squares here the
problem for white is these Knights are
well placed to jump into the weakened
squares on c4 white tries to play Queen
b3 keeping the knight out of c4 but
black now simply continues with 95 and
all of his pieces are coming to life we
see Bishop f3 this Bishop guarding
against this diagonal if White had just
played pretty normally with a move like
I don't know let's say rook d1 he would
run into Knight takes c3 rook takes c3
and now Bishop d5 this is likely what
kappa blanka was trying to avoid this
move Bishop d3 or Bishop f3 rather
instead though the the new problem with
Bishop f3 is it just totally gives up
the c-4 square and now Alekhine makes
great use of it to activate his pieces
and win this game knightly 4 was White's
choice black simply supports this rook
further with queen c8 you see rook takes
c4 now Knight takes d4 and black is the
one with all of the activity rook c1
from White's now the Queen has served
his purpose on c8 and jumps over to a 8
putting more pressure along this long
diagonal white now brings this knight
back to c3 finally challenging this
knight on d5 but this turns out to be a
pretty bad move rook c8 from black is
perfectly fine and after the trades we
have this position here and it turns out
black is simply dominating in this
position there's no way to stop the
black pieces from invading here white
tried a 4 but now after Bishop f6 the
knight jumps back to f3
and the what the black pieces are
already invading note that if white
tried to keep this diagonal closed
there's really no good way to do it can
play a move like rook d1 but you're
simply going to run into B takes a4 and
after Queen takes a four-night b2
there's just no way to stop the black
pieces from getting in so Knight f3 but
this allows Bishop b2 the black rook has
to move of course once again if you come
to d1 you run into some tactics in this
case of course the tactic is Knight
takes III defending the Queen attacking
the rook and attacking the white queen
of course after rook takes d5 you run
into rook c1 check with back rank
problems and at the end of the day black
is gonna be up a full pawn and this pawn
will not be long for this world either
so now if the rook has to come to e 1
and this is rather unfortunate for white
simply rook d8 and black has control of
the open files take some b5 take some b5
and now white tries to move h3 trying to
solve some of these back rank problems
but kappa blanka finally breaks through
he needs to get to this D 2 square and
to do that he has to get rid of this
Knight so what does he do he simply
plays he five with the idea of efore
removing this Knight rook b1 was kept of
Blancas choice but now Eve 4 still comes
on the board and after 94 we see some
clever tactics to finish off the game
Bishop takes d4 rook d1 then of course
the final move of the game I'm sure you
all see it at home
it's that same tactic we saw before
Knight takes III hitting this Queen and
after I move like Queen takes d5 you get
hit with rook takes d5 and you cannot
capture the knight back or else you get
checked a very nice game from Alekhine a
very nice finishing move to end the game
no way to regain the piece for white a
very nice game from Alekhine out playing
kappa blanka using the only open file on
the board blocking the other file with
this knight using the key C 4 square and
with that thank you very much for
joining me on this episode of
my name is Caleb Denby and I will see
you next time